hello everyone and welcome to the other
game that we are going to cover from the
uh super bet chess classic round five it
is a former World Chase Championship
Challenger Yanni partnership versus
Maxim Rachelle lagrav uh both of them
already lost the game in the tournament
and they would very much love to come
back so let's see what happened in this
one nipple has the white pieces and he
started with Ponte E4 and something that
we should definitely mention before
checking out the game is uh nepo has a
great score against pretty much everyone
in classical chess except Maxine because
against Maxine Nepal has only one win he
has six losses and they have 10 more
draws so that's a pretty terrible score
to have against someone in classical and
Nepal would definitely enjoy beating
Maxim here with the white pieces so here
Max thing was for C5 as usually that's
the Sicilian Defense and nepo tries
spawned the C3 the all up in variation
we have Pawn to D5 captures captures and
pawn to D4 this is the uh the main line
the Bremen the defense by black we have
Knight to F6 Knight to F3 and now Ponte
E6 with Knight the A3 bringing the
Knight to C4 Ponte A6 Knights the C4 and
now Knight B to D7 we have Pawn to A4
and the B6 so this has all been played
before nothing new here uh Bishop to E2
with Bishop to B7 nicely positioning the
bishop and Queen on this diagonal
castles and C captures on D4 now of
course now the Knight cannot capture you
would just get a checkmated on G2 but
you can capture with the queen offering
a queen trade with Bishop to C5 of
course nipple would um enjoy the trade
happening on D5 but here we have Queen
to H4 uh
nipple was for this very new tricky move
because the moves that have been played
before are queen to F4 and queen
captures on D5 but after Queen to H4
it's a new move so now as of move 12 we
have a completely new game uh how does
Maxime deal with this he plays Queen the
E4 offers the queen trade once again
and now Network accepts a bot on e4 so
captures captures he trades on his terms
uh Knight after D2 offering a trade of
knights and Knight E back to F6 with
Knight to B3 now pressuring the bishop
and the bishop back to E7 with Bishop to
F4 now really fighting for that D6
square if you can put the rook and D1
should be should be excellent uh and
just Bishop to D5 now we're pressuring
both of the knights here we have Rook
after D1 and now uh just Castles by MBL
we have Knight beat the D2 you don't
want that Knight looking sillion B3 and
Rook F the C8 putting more pressure on
that C4 knight uh we have Knight to E3
attacking the bishop and the just Bishop
going back to C6 we have knighted D back
to C4 and pawn to A5 now uh we have
Knights the D6 finally winning that D6
square and you don't want this monster
Knight here so you just have to give up
the bishop pair for it so Bishop
captures with Bishop captures on D6 you
could also consider Rook captures on G6
but Bishop captures and G6 D6 seems to
be offering you a bit more uh because
now it's very hard to kick it away from
there but of course as usual there
always is a way Knight to C5 the Knight
is now coming to B7 and will put
pressure on the Bishop from there on D6
and this is what Maxim went in the meant
in the quote above the board uh we have
Bishop to B5 now Knight to B7 attacking
the bishop and the bishop back to A3 we
have rooked the C7 uh and now Pawn to F3
we have Rook 8 the C8 doubling up on the
C file Rook to D2 preparing to double up
on the D file Ponte H6 and Rook 8 D1
here we have a trade Bishop capture
spawn captures and here MBO just plays
King to H7 and he says that okay the
Knight here is a bit weird but uh he's
doing a fine job he's he's two knights
are definitely controlling a lot of
squares here this is defended by this
side this is defended by this Knight so
the Rooks can't really do anything along
the the file also the the cover is
sufficiently protected so you can't
really lift anything here so here King
to F2 Nepal starts bringing his King
into the game and pawn to G5 by mvl with
Ponte H4 and just King to G6 with h
captors and G5 H captors and now Pawn to
G4 uh nipple also maybe uh with some
ideas of using the H files file to his
Advantage but the mvl grabs hold of it
first we have Rook h a rook to h8 King
to G3 and now Rook C the C8 now he's
preparing to double up on the H file we
have Ponta C4 and now Rook the H7 so uh
still not a lot of use for the Rooks on
the on the D file with Bishop to D6 and
now we have Knight the D7 uh we have
Pawn to B3 and pawn to F6 now we have
Bishop back to A3 now nipple is Shifting
the bishop over to this diagonal but now
Knight to E5 and this Knight is putting
a lot of pressure on White's position in
here as you'll see very soon we have
Bishop to B2 but now Rooks C to h8 and
all of a sudden there are some dangers
here along the H file we have King to F2
the problem is uh none of the choices
you have are particularly good you could
eliminate the knight from E5 but you
know that giving up this bishop is
pretty bad long term because after let's
say Knight to F1 E4 is coming and this
is uh not easy to hold if you for
example if you capture then Rook the H3
check comes then you can pick up the B3
Pawn uh not not great so another thing
you could do is play Knight to F1 right
away it will keep an eye on the H2
Square so you don't have to worry about
the check and check but still the F3
Pawn is attacked and you you could just
lose it for example Rook to H3 with
checking G2 Knight captures and F2
attacks the rook and you have to play
some sort of a passive move like Rook to
E2 and while the engine says okay maybe
white can hold this uh you kind of don't
believe that No No One Believes that uh
so King Dev 2 was played and now Knights
the C5 by Maxine putting pressure on
that B3 pawn and here uh nipple uh he he
was playing very quickly because Maxine
was low on time and he really wanted to
pressure him he played Bishop captures
on E5 which is um uh the the best move
according to the engine but this
position in itself isn't all that great
with f captures and E5 now Rook to D6 he
tries to go for some sort of a an active
plan now can I capture some B3 will be
met with Rook captures on E6 but Maxine
plays Rook to H2 with check and now King
to G1 if you block with the Knight then
you just run into E4 this is terrible
for white uh yeah you can't really do
anything here if you capture here then
Knight captures an E4 with check and
your position just uh you know is
completely ruined and he plays something
like Rook to D to try and trade off a
pair of Rooks then Rook comes to H3 and
again nah you're not coming coming out
of this alive so King to G1 was played
by nepo now comes with Rook to H1 check
King the F2 and now Rook want the HD
with check King back to G1 and now Pawn
to E4 and what can you play here again
not a lot uh capturing this doesn't
really do anything you just allow the
other Rook to come to H3 and then white
is pretty much without a move so Knight
to F1 was played attacking The Rook here
Rook the B2 going after the pawn and now
Rook captures on B6 saying that okay if
you move the Knight I'm gonna capture an
E6 and I'm gonna be fine but Maxine
plays e captures on F3 we have rooked D2
offering a rook trade and now Rook the
B1 we have rooked the C6 uh now
threatening to pick up the Knight and
again hoping for Knight captures on B3
to be able to play Rook captures on E6
but Maxim finds a way and there is only
one way to win this game and it's it's
uh it's a very long forcing line but if
you calculate it right you two can be
the winner of this game so feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
maxim uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this
beautiful move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy it is Rook captures
an F1 that's the move that finishes the
job Rook captures the only move you have
is King captors and now Rook to H1 with
check as these two squares are covered
your only move is King to F2 and now you
run into this Fork Knights the E4 with
check we have King captures on F3 and
now Knight captures and D2 with check
for King The King and the pawn on B3 so
King E3 Knight captures on B3 now mvl is
up a full piece but nipple still has the
two connected past pawns uh and uh it's
not all clear if he can stop them so
Pawn to B6 but now Rook to H3 with check
again mvl has to be engine precise here
in order to win this King F2 now Rook
the h8 now the back rank is being
covered by the rook and the problem is
if you play B7 just Rook the B8 and
you're covered so here nepo tries Rook
captures on E6 with check King the F7
attacks the rook and now rookie 5. if he
can maybe eliminate all of the pawns
then still it's gonna be great for him
however Pawn to A4 and now what do you
play here Rook the B5 putting the Rogue
behind the pass Pawn also A3 is
impossible because of Rook captures uh
King to E6 not a problem we have King to
E3 and here we have Pawn to A3 and he
was in this position unmove uh 58 that
Yani pomach resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here the
problem is now if you capture the Knight
with Rook captures on B3 Ponte A2 and
how are you stopping the pawn you can't
go to B1 and of course if you put the
Rook to A3 then Rook the H3 check comes
which was the whole point of forcing the
king to come to E3 so obviously that
loses on the spot and on the other hand
if you play something like Pawn to B7 to
try and promote here you can promote but
you are much to uh too slow Ponte 2b8
Queen Rook captures uh Rook captures and
now A1 Queen you do get to pick up the
Knight but now it's a queen against The
Rook of course this is completely
winning uh you can win this many
different ways like you can play some
like Queen here with check or you can
just play Queen to G1 with check pick up
the G4 Pawn then let's say trade the
queen for The Rook push the Jeep onto
Victory there are so many ways to
winning this and of course
um and apple knows this so after point a
three Nepal resigned and that's pretty
much it for those of you who are
interested in the standings after five
rounds of the super bet chess classic as
tomorrow is a rest day so we're gonna
cover games from other tournaments as
well as there are quite a lot of them
being played and I have seen your
suggestions so don't worry you have been
heard these are the standings after
round five so far be leading the
tournament with three and a half points
we have a three-way tie uh for for
second third and fourth alirez
Rapport then with two and a half points
we have a nichigiri and Maxima shell
Agra with two points
dingler and young sister do that you can
see that the world champion and the
former World Championship Challenger uh
are not not uh very close to at the the
top of the leaderboard but you know okay
it's still early maybe something shifts
and the Local Hero Bogdan Daniel Dak
currently in last place with one and a
half points so there we have it a lot of
fun here not a lot of fun for the former
World Chess Championship Challenger and
the current world champion Ding and
nipple uh but you know the tournament's
still young it might um you know you
know pick up for them and go their way
but we'll see what happens uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh and uh you know if you ever feel like
unveil did that your position was as mvl
felt you know don't despair you know
good things might happen uh so yeah I
would like to thank Edmund Freeman Evan
bersey ravishing reptiles YouTube Lord
of Bones and Mazin El sarak for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
everything else that's happening in the
Chess World and after the rest the day
finishes of course coming back to this
wonderful classical event uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day